this is a crucial day for nearly all of
the Democratic presidential hopefuls New
Hampshire is holding its traditional
primary contest that gives some
candidates a boost and forces others out
of the race
Donita copal is at cafe Lauren in
Manchester New Hampshire's largest city
Tony how's it looking looking pretty
good so far Anthony good morning guys
they call it cafe Loran it means the
Queen in Manchester is the Queen City
because it is the largest but not the
Capitol but this is the capital of
politics in America today it's basically
a two-step process people line up for
coffee at places like this and then
they're gonna be lining up at polling
stations all around the state in fact
the first voters have already begun to
line up and the first votes are in in
this first-in-the-nation contest they
were counted just after midnight five
people in the tiny town of dixville
notch and three of them wrote in Mike
Bloomberg's name that's some breaking
news for you the former New York City
Mayor isn't on the ballot here at all
which is why he was a write-in Dixville
notch was one of three towns to open
their polls at midnight and their
combined results show here's another
surprise Amy Klobuchar she has been
surging and she's leading the Democratic
primary so far important words there so
far all of the candidates have made
their final appeals to voters all across
the state yesterday they were
criss-crossing it but Democrats were not
the only ones making a pitch President
Trump was here he held a major rally in
Manchester this very City last night and
he promised his supporters here that he
will win New Hampshire in a landslide
his words come November today's primary
is getting extra attention after the
disaster at the Iowa caucuses but New
Hampshire secretary of state bill
Gardner he told us he slept well last
night and today's voting will be simple
and secure you're saying it's not broke
and you're not fixing it it just works
keep it simple keep the moving parts the
smallest number you can
could this be hacked in any way it can't
hack a pencil how many apps do you have
involved in this process we don't have
any app involved in the tabulating of
the comments no apps no app it's an app
free election you can guarantee that yes
free fair and app free that's the
guarantee from the Secretary of State
here